قال المبعوث الامامي الى ليبيا عبد الله
باتيلي انه يعتزم اطلاق مبادره للتمكين من
اجراء انتخابات رئاسيه وبرلمانيه في ليبيا
قد لا نهايه العام الجالي باتيلي قال في
احاطه قدمها الى مجلس الامن انه سيشكل
لجنه لدفع قدوما بتوافقات بين اطراف
الازمه الليبيه بشان الانتخابات وتذليل
الخلافات خاصه المتمحور حول القاعده
الدستوريه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي
الاسس التي بنى عليها المبعوث الامي
المبادره التي طرحها لاجراء انتخابات
رئاسيه وتشريعيه في ليبيا وهل في بنودها
ما يضمن قبول اطراف الازمه بها ويؤمن
نجاحها
كيف لاطراف الازمه الليبيه ان تتعامل مع
هذه المبادره الاماميه في ضوء الخلافات
التي تمحورت حول نقاط خلافيه اصاب التعثر
محاولات عده لتجاوزها
وما الذي سيترتب عن انطلاق المبادره
الامميه نحو اعمال بنودها او الفشل في ذلك
وهو ما يرتبط بتعقيدات بين المصاعب التي
تعترض مفاوضات مجلسي النواب والاعلى
للدوله حول القاعده الدستوريه
[موسيقى]
عيله صبر الامم المتحده ومن ورائها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والدول
الغربيه وهي تسعى لطي الفتره الانتقاليه
في ليبيا
وبات الحل المطروح لتحريك المياه الراكده
للازمه السياسيه في البلاد اجراء انتخابات
رئاسيه وتشريعيه قبل ان تنقضي السنه
الجاريه ذا كما تنطق به المبادره التي
اعلن عنها المبعوث الامامي الى ليبيا عبد
الله بتيل قائلا انها تستند الى الماده
الرابعه والستين من الاتفاق السياسي العام
بين الاطراف الليبيه سنه 2015
باتيلي اضافنا المبادره ستعتمد لجنه عليا
مهمتها الدفع بالتوافقات بشان الانتخابات
قدما وتفعيلها واقرب تيلي بان تنفيذ
الانتخابات يتطلب توافقا وطنيا واسعا داخل
البلاد وان مؤسسات الدوله الحاليه فقدت
شرعيته
بتيلي يشير بذلك الى الخلافات الواسعه
داخل النخب السياسيه ومنها ما يفصل بين
مجلس النواب والمجلس الاعلى للدوله
والتوافق حول القاعده الدستوريه وتعيش
ليبيا ازمه سياسيه مستمره في ظل حكومتين
احداهما حكومه الوحده الوطنيه التي يراسها
عبد الحميد الدبيبه والذي يرفض التسليم
الا لحكومه من برلمان المنتخب
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من طرابلس محمد
محفوظ الباحث والمحلل السياسي ومن بنغازي
احمد محمد الكاتبه الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
ينضم الينا ايضا من اسطنبول السنوسي
بسيكري مدير المركز الليبي للبحوث
والتنميه ابدا معك سيد محمد محفوظ
ما هي الاسس التي قامت عليها هذه المبادره
لماذا الان وما هي الظروف التي دفعت بعبد
الله باتيلي الى تقديم مبادره من هذا
النوع على الرغم من الخلافات
بين الطرفين الرئيسيين وحتى داخل
هذين او الاجنحه داخل هذين الطرفين
استاذ حسن لك ولضيوفك وايضا لمشاهدي
الجزيره الكرام طبعا هذه الاحاطه كان
متوقعا فيها ان يعلن ان يعلن السيد عبد
الله بتيلي عن هذه اللجنه العليا التي
سماها لجنه الدفع بالعمليه الانتخابيه وهي
التي
ستشكل قاعده دستوريه وقانون انتخابيه تذهب
بالبلاد نحو الانتخابات المحصله التي خرج
بها مجلسين نواب والدوله الشريكين
الرئيسيين في العمليه السياسيه منذ سنه
مضت يدور هذين جسمين في ذات الفلك وهو فلك
الفشل وتمطيط المرحله الانتقاليه وعدم
التوافق على القاعده الدستوريه كان اخرها
استاذ حسن هو انجاز التعديل الدستوري
الثالث عشر الذي اخرجه مجلس النواب بطريقه
غير دستوريه وغير قانونيه وبالتالي
سيد محفوظ حتى لا نعيد الاحداث كل ما
تقوله
اصبح واضحا لكن السؤال ما الذي تغير الان
يعني ما الذي يضمن ان تنجح هذه المبادره
الطرفان المختلفان ما زال على الساحه
القاعده الدستوريه لم يتفق بشانها
وبالتالي ما الذي تغير حتى تطرح في هذا
الظرف
اولا اللجنه التي سيعلنها السيد بتيلي في
قادم الايام لن يكون فيها تمثيل المجلسين
الا على الهامش وبالتالي لن يكون المجلسين
او رئيسي كلا المجلسين هما الوحيدين
المتحكمين في العمليه السياسيه وفي مساله
القاعده الدستوريه سيكون هناك اقام
ومشاركه للقبائل ونخب سياسيه كذلك الشباب
والمراه وبالتالي وجود المجلسين فيه على
الهامش لن يؤثر بشكل او اخر على انجاز هذا
الامر اضافه الى عامل اخر في تقدير وهو
عامل مهم وهو مساله الاهتمام الدولي
المتزايد الذي اصبح امرا لا يمكن اخفائه
خاصه اهتمام الولايات المتحده في ليبيا
وبشان السياسي الليبي قاده الولايات
المتحده طيله الايام الماضيه جهود وسطات
قبل احاطت بتيري تحديدا كان هناك اجتماع
في واشنطن في الثاني والعشرين من فبراير
وبالتالي هذا الاجتماع الذي استطاعت روايه
المتحده ان تبلور ولو بشكل جزئي موقفا
دوليا داعما لهذه الحاطه اعلنها بتيري
اعتقد كلا العاملين الذي تحدثت عنهما
سيكون في تقدير عام النجاح لهذه اللجنه
التي هل بامكان هل بامكان او بالامكان
تهميش هذين الطرفين لصالح
لجنه ستكون هناك اسئله حول شرعيتها ايضا
السؤال هنا للسيد احمد محمد حول هذه
المبادره وان كانت فعلا
يمكن ان تسير في اتجاه اجراء
انتخابات نيابيه ورياسيه في ليبيا هذا
العام
نعم يعني في الحقيقه هذه المبادره لا
تختلف عن الحوار السياسي الذي جرى في عام
2014 و2015 وايضا بعد الحرب الاخيره في
طرابلس هذه المبادرات الامميه يعني اثبتت
خلال سنوات الماضيه انها لم تستطع ان تصل
الى نتيجه حقيقيه يعني كل ما يتم بعد هذه
المبادرات هو مثلا فرض سلطه او حكومه
جديده هذه الحكومه ربما تستطيع ان تدخل
الى العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس وتستلم
الاداره ولكنها لن تستطيع الوصول الى حل
ينهي الانقسام لان البعثه الامميه
والمجتمع الدولي يعني بشكل عام لا توجد
لديه اليات واضحه لفرض هذه الحلول وفرض
يعني اجنده خارطه الطريق التي توضع او
نتائج الحوار الذي تشرف عليه بعثه الامم
المتحده دعنا ننظر الى اخر مبادره يعني
اشرفت عليها بعثه الامم المتحده والتي
انتجت حكومه الوحده الوطنيه في طرابلس هذه
الحكومه وصلت الى السلطه عن طريق
تسعه وثلاثين صوتا من من شاركوا في لجنه
الحوار وهي لجنه غير منتخبه وهذه الحكومه
يعني لم تصل بالبلاد الى الانتخابات ولم
تنجح في توحيد البلاد وانهاء الخلافات
والانقسامات الحاصله نعم
سيد سنوس بسيكري هل هل ثمه ما يضمن نجاح
هذه المبادره اما انها كغيرها ربما
تكون حراكا امنيا ودوليا لكنه لن ينتج ما
هو مامول منه
وانا اعتقد بان الصعوبات والتحديات امام
اي مبادره تطرح من قبل المنتظم الدولي
ليست فقط يعني اشكاليتها في قصورها من
ناحيه التصميم ولكن في الاشكاليات الحقيقه
على الارض المشهد
السياسي والامني والاجتماعي حتى الليبي
معقد جدا وليس من السهل انك انت تطرح فيه
اي حلقه للتنفيذ بيسر وسهوله لماذا لجا
بتيلي الى هذا الطرح الى البحث عن مسار
بديل عن المجلسين لان المجلسان منذ سنوات
طويله نعود الى ما بعد الاقسام 2014
لم ينجح في توافق حقيقي يفكك الازمه
الليبيه بل ان فعلهما
وتوافقاتهما كانت جزء من التعقيد ولم تكن
جزءا من الحل
فما يدفع البتيل وغيره من سبقوه الملتقى
الحوار السياسي التي بنيتها ستيفاني انما
هو بسبب فشل المجالس في ان تقارب الازمه
الليبيه بحل مقبول
وما ترسى لدى الداخل والخارج لدى المجتمع
الدولي ولا لدى المجتمع الليبي ان
المجلسان يريدان لا يريدان انتخابات
ويريدان
هذا هو التعقيد الذي
هذا التعقيد الذي دفع باتجاه هذه المبادره
لكن السؤال هل ما يضمن نجاح هذه المبادره
من التعقيد مستمر يعني ولا يمكن تجاهل
للمجلسين حتى اللجنه التي تحدث عنها عبد
الله تحدث عنها عبد الله باتيلي قد تكون
موضع خلاف حتى خلاف ربما بين اطرافها فضلا
عن السؤال عن مشروعيتها باختصار
لا ضمان لنجاح هذه المبادره يعني ملتقى
الحوار السياسي كان مقاربه دوليه من
مدعومه امريكيا استطاعت ان تنجز جزءا من
حل الازمه وهو التوافق على السلطه
التنفيذيه لكنها لم تستطع ان تدفع الاطراف
للتوافق على القوانين الانتخابيه واجراء
الانتخابات كان موعد الانتخابات يوم 20 24
ديسمبر 2021 ولم تتحقق ولم تجدي هذه
المبادره مبادره ست المدعومه امريكيا
واوروبيا من ان تعالج الواقع فلا ضمان الا
في استمرار الضغط الشديد من قبل الامريكان
الذين تحركوا خلال الاشهر القليله الماضيه
حرك لها اثار على الواقع ان استمر الضغط
الامريكي بشكل مباشر على الاطراف المعرقله
يمكن ان نرى نتائج ايجابيه طيب
الاطراف
المعرقلان يعني بالحديث عن الاطراف داخل
ليبيا اول ردود الفعل على احاطه المبعوث
الاممي الى ليبيا مجلس النواب الليبي
انتقد الاحاطه التي قدمها المبعوث الامم
عبد الله باتيلي قائلا في بيان اصدره
نستغرب ما تضمنته احاطه المبعوث الاممي من
مغالطات بشان فشل مجلسي النواب والدوله في
اقرار القاعده الدستوريه اعود اليك سيد
محفوظ يعني كل الاحاطه اساسا هي محل
انتقاد من مجلس
النواب يعني
ربما هذا الامر متوقع لكن نعود الى مضمون
هذه المبادره لعبد الله بتيلي نفس هذه
يعني نفس اللجنه التي ستشكل هل هناك ما
يضمن ان تتفق على قاعده دستوريه والتي هي
الاساس في اختلاف المجلسين اصلا
نعم بكل تاكيد استاذ حسن ليس هناك ضمانات
في المشهد السياسي الليبي اطلاقا وبالتالي
اليوم اعتقد اننا على قناعه تامه اننا لا
يمكننا ان نثق في مسار يقوده مجلسين نواب
والدوله وان نعول عليه انه سيكون في نهايه
هذا المسار انتخابات كما يصبر لها لبيون
لاننا قد جربنا هذا المسار وجربنا مجيسين
نواب والدوله وكيل الجسمين قد اثبت فشلهما
وبالتالي نحن كليبيون ليس لدينا مفر الا
اللجوء الى هذه الخيارات التي يعني اذا ما
استندنا الى خيارات شبه مشابهه لها يعني
اذا ما تحدثنا على ملتقى الحوار السياسي
قد نجح في بعض الاشياء وقد فشل في بعض
الاشياء الاخرى وحتى فشل هذا الامر اعتقد
انه له عده اسباب كان هناك مبعوث اممي
جديد يانكوفيتش انذاك السلم بعد ستيفن
ويليامز وتدخلت اطراف دوليه افشلت ملتقى
الحوار السياسي وبالتالي حتى الفشل له
حديث وله نقاش اخر الامر المهم اليوم انا
اعتقد ان مساله النجاح هذه هذه مرتبطه
بعده امور الامر الاول هو مساله الدعم
الدولي كما تحدث السيد مسيكري قبل قليل
اذا استمرت دعم الامريكي والضغط الامريكي
تجاه نجاح هذه اللجنه اعتقد ان النجاح
سيكون حليفا الامر الثاني ايضا انا دائما
مؤكد على امرهم اننا اذا اردنا انتخابات
في ليبيا يجب ان نشرك اصحاب المصلحه في
اجراء هذه الانتخابات وهذا الذي فعله بتيل
اليوم عندما نشرك زعماء القبائل والمكونات
الاجتماعيه نشرك الشباب والمراه نشرك
الاحزاب السياسيه كذلك نشرب نشرك نخب
سياسيه هي ليست موجوده في السلطه كل هؤلاء
استاذ حسن هم اصحاب مصلحه في شراء
الانتخابات وبالتالي انا اعتقد ان هذا
العامل سيكون عاملا حفازه لهؤلاء لمساله
ذهاب قدم نحو انتخابات الامر الثالث صحيح
بتيري اليوم في حاطته لم لم اسمح لي استاذ
حسن مرهم باتيني في حطته لم يتكلم عن
تفاصيل ولكن هناك خطه تم تسريبها قبل ايام
قليله من احاطه بتيري الخطه الثلاثيه من
الدول الثلاثيه الدائمه 3 بيب فرنسا
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا تتحدث هذه
الخطه واعتقد ان هذه الخطه هي الذي هي
التي تبناها السيد البتيري الخطه تتحدث عن
خيارات بديله واضحه في حاله فشل هذه
اللجنه وتتحدث عن اجال زمنيه صارمه
وبالتالي انا اعتقد التفصيل الذي تحدثت
عنه هذه الخطه الثلاثيه ان اعتقد انها
ستكون ضمانا وربما يمكن من خلالها ان
نستشعر ان المجتمع الدولي حريص على نجاح
هذه اللجنه سيد احمد محمد هل يمكن ان يفرض
هذا الحل من الخارج على الداخل
يعني رغم الرفض ربما الذي ستلقاه هذه
المبادره بشكل الذي تحدث عنه عبد الله
باتيلي
نعم يمكن ان تفرض هذه الحلول كما جرى في
عام 2015 و 2016 وايضا يعني كما جرى في
لجنه الحوار الاخيره التي انتجت الحكومه
الوحده الوطنيه ولكن الواقع في ليبيا يبدو
لي انه تغير نوعا ما هو السلطات الليبيه
اصبحت يعني اكثر سيطره على مواقعها
الجغرافيه ولكن يعني ما اراه انا شخصيا ان
هذه لا توافقات التي حدثت مؤخرا بين مجلس
النواب والمجلس الاعلى للدوله من المفترض
ان يتم البناء عليها والذهاب بها الى
الامام يعني هذه هي او عن تتحدث قد انتهت
نعم اتحدث يعني عن التوافقات الاخيره التي
جرت بين
البرلمان وبين المجلس الاعلى للدوله
واقرار الاعلان عفوا التعديل الدستوري
الثالث عشر وهو يعني ما اراه انه محاوله
ليبيه ربما يكتب لها النجاح يعني ما جرى
في عام 2015 وايضا بعد حرب طرابلس كان
هنالك تقارب بين الاطراف الليبيه ولكن
بعثه الامم المتحده جاءت وتدخلت ويعني
قامت من خلال مبادرات اخرى خارج هذا
الاطار وخارج التفاهمات الليبيه الليبيه
بفرض حلول على الاطراف الليبيه وهذه
الحلول لم تؤدي في الحقيقه الى انهاء
الانقسام وانهاء الازمه ولكنها ساهمت في
تعقيد ليبيه
وربما اكون مخطئا ولكن اختصارا انه من
المفترض اختصارا للوقت فقط يعني
نفهم منك بانه اذا جرى فرض هذا الامر من
الخارج دون موافقه المجلس الاعلى للدوله
ومجلس النواب ستزداد المشاكل والانقسامات
ولن تنجح في اجراء انتخابات رئاسيه
وتشريعيه كما يطمع المبعوث الاممي
بالتاكيد لذلك يجب على البعثه الامميه ان
تقوم بالبناء على التوافقات الاخيره التي
حدثت بين البرلمان ومجلس الدوله وتمضي
بهذه التوفقات الى الامام حتى تقطع الحجه
امام هذين المجلسين وربما كما قلت لك يعني
هذه المبادره الليبيه الليبيه ربما يعني
تصل الى حل بطريقه ما او باخرى بعيدا عن
تعقيد الازمه عندما يعني دائما تتدخل
البعثه الاماميه في رايي لتنتج مسارات
موازيه تزيد تعقيد الازمنه
وسائل الضغط الامريكيه يعني بكلامك قبل
قليل شعرت وكانك تعول اكثر على الضغط
الامريكي مع العلم ان هناك اطراف دوليه
متداخله في الازمه الليبيه كان اوروبيه او
حتى
اقليميه ما هي وسائل الضغط الامريكيه على
الاطراف في الداخل للسير بهذه المبادره
ونعتقد بان السعي الامريكي والجهد
الامريكيه يعني متحركه بفاعليه منذ اشهر
وصول مدير وكاله المخابرات الامريكيه الى
طرابلس والى بنغازي والتقاء بهم شخصيتين
في رايي انا هم من يستطيع
عرقله مسيره التسويه السياسيه والانتخابات
دبيبه في الغرب وحفتر في الشرق انا اعتقد
بان بالامكان لدى الامريكان ان يفرضوا
تفاهمات
بطريقه العصا والجزره هناك ما يؤشر ان
دبيبه
وحفتر يتناغمان مع طرح الامريكي الضغوط
التي مارستها واشنطن على القاهره فيما
يتعلق بسير التسويه السياسيه تصريحات
عجيله صالح من انه يجب انزاجه انجاز شيء
قبل نهايه شهر مارس والا فان الحل قادم من
الخارج لا محاله هذه كلها تشير بان الضغوط
الامريكيه قويه على جميع الاطراف وانما
وقع من توافق شكلي في رايي الشخصي بين
المجلسين
ثمظهر في التعديل الدستوري الثالث عشر هو
التوافق شكلي لماذا لانه تم نزع اساس
الخلاف بينهما وهو موضوع الشروط شروط
الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه هذه هي نقطه الخلاف
منذ ثلاثه سنوات تم استبعادها واستثناءها
من النقاش فتم التوافق الشكلي فشكل
التعديل الثالث عشر لكن وهذا ما دفع ما
دفع نعم عفوا لانه لم يعد لدينا مزيد
موضوع موضوع
المتعلق بهذه المبادره لو فشلت
ماذا سيترتب عليها وقلت ان ربما عبد الله
باتيلي بنى او راى راى بارقه امل ربما من
هذه من هذا التوافق بين المجلسين لكن ماذا
لو فشلت باختصار
فشلت محاوله بتيلي انا اعتقد بانها لن
تفشل نهائيا انا اعتقد بانه سيستطيع تشكيل
هذه اللجنه هذه اللجنه ستتوافق على قاعده
دستوريه بديله وستضع اطارا للقوانين
قوانين الانتخابات ففي هذا الشق سيحقق
انجاز وستطيع اعلى المجتمع الدولي ان
اختراقا قد وقع وتطورا قد وقع لكن على
الارض هل سيتم اقناع كل الاطراف المعنيه
بالتجاوب مع القاعده الدستوريه الجديده
والقوانين الانتخابيه ان لم تحل مشكله
الترشح للانتخابات الرئيسيه بمعنى جماعه
سبتمبر داعمين سيف الاسلام ان تم استبعاده
ستقع مشكله جماعه الكرامه داعمين حفتر تم
استبعاده ستقع مشكله جماعه فبراير يناورون
على بعض الشخصيه في مقدمتها دبيبه ان تم
استبعادها تم مشكله المشكله ان المكونات
الثلاث لا تتفق على هؤلاء المرشحين
الثلاثه فالازمه في رايي الشخصي ليست
بالقريب حلها وتحتاج الى مرحله اطول الى
توافقات في الداخل ضغوط من الخارج يمكن ان
تسفر عن حل يدفعنا الى الاستقرار شكرا لك
مدير المركز الليبي للبحوث والتنميه من
اسطنبول شكرا لاحمد محمد الكاتبه الصحفي
والمحل السياسي من بنغازي وشكرا لمحمد
محفوظ الذي كان معنا من طرابلس الباحث
والمحلل السياسي ايضا
انتهت حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]